the once untouchable drug boss known as
el chapo was likely to spend 23 hours a
day in a high-security prison cell for
the rest of his life
a jury in Brooklyn New York convicted
Joaquin Guzman yesterday on all 10
counts of a federal indictment including
engaging in canoe in gauging rather in a
continuing criminal enterprise drug
trafficking and money laundering
his three-month trial completed a
decades-long effort by US officials to
bring the fugitive to justice
his lawyers plan to appeal Jericka
Duncan is outside the federal courthouse
in Brooklyn Jericho good morning good
morning that jury deliberated for six
days before reaching that unanimous
verdict now throughout the trial they
heard from more than 50 witnesses who
really laid bare el Chapo's brutal and
bloody reign as head of the Sinaloa drug
cartel his conviction is a victory for
the American people who has suffered so
long and so much while Guzman made
billions for federal prosecutors it was
a sweeping victory Joaquin el chapo
guzman guilty on all counts and now
facing life without parole is a sentence
from which there is no escape and no
return El Chapo will likely be sent to
the supermax prison in Colorado one of
the homes to the nation's most dangerous
inmates including Boston Marathon bomber
Dzhokhar tsarnaev and the 1993 World
Trade Center bombing say Youssef el
Chapo's former associates testified how
he ordered the torture and murder of
rivals and defectors sometimes carrying
out the violent deeds himself El Chapo
who famously escaped from Mexican
prisons twice once evaded capture by
running naked through a sewer according
to his mistress he hid narcotics inside
planes submarines even cans of jalapeno
peppers a sophisticated multi-billion
dollar operation that spanned decades
CBS News legal analysts Ricky cleamen
what we learned in this trial is how a
international drug trafficking empire
works it is run like a fortune 100
corporation facing a mountain of
evidence that
it's called just one witness and rested
its case after about 30 minutes El Chapo
did not take the stand after the guilty
verdict was read he flashed a thumbs-up
sign to his teary-eyed wife defense
attorney Jeffrey Lichtman this was not a
case where we had a defendant presumed
innocent he was presumed guilty El Chapo
will be sentenced here in June now the
Sinaloa drug cartel that he once led
still makes billions from drug
trafficking bianna it's considered one
of the most powerful criminal
organizations in Mexico this has been a
fascinating and frightening trial to
watch play out dareka thank you